ah ouais si boutros boutros ghali
la barre
un maire la hausse au laurent baffie
lorànt deutsch boutros boutros ghali
alors le nom de monsieur boutros ghali
vous faisait beaucoup rire tout à
l'heure c'est pas que ça me faisait rire
c'est que c'est vrai que je me suis posé
la question parce que moi j'ai des
voisins de palier il s'appelle le nom de
famille c'est jeanjean est le prénom du
fils et jean luc et donc j'ai vu une
parenthèse boutros boutros ghali et je
me faisais je sais pas la signification
parce que vous appelez botman c'est
boutros ghali et votre y annoncer
boutros ouais c'est qu'au bout tracé
lala de pétrole de peter alors c'est
pierre pierre galy ségalis aigaliers way
arabe ça veut dire qu'à de la valeur
ok merci d'avoir choisi tout le monde en
parle où trop de boutros ghali dont vous
avez été secrétaire général de l'onu de
1992 à 1996
vous avez été également ministre des
affaires étrangères d'égypte et
aujourd'hui vous êtes secrétaire général
de l'organisation internationale de la
francophonie voilà donc vous êtes issu
de la bourgeoisie égyptienne riches
familles coptes dans les chrétiens
d'égypte qui représente comme 10% de la
population en egypte et comme louis donc
votre grand père a été le premier
premier ministre non musulmans d'égypte
il était malheureusement assassiné et
votre famille est traditionnellement aux
services de l'état
vous êtes un enfant de la diplomatie
quand j'étais petit ou demander qu'est
ce que tu veux faire plus tard
vous disiez politiciens comme maison que
mon grand père voilà c'est ça c'est
juste c'est juste
alors j'ai fait une licence de droit au
coeur en 46 vous venez à paris et là
c'est une parenthèse un petit peu
rigolote dans votre vie quand même vous
pourrez un appartement rue monsieur le
prince est un peu playboy à l'époque non
je te donne toute petite chambre comme
ça oui bon c'est petit mais il y avait
quand même un double séjour la chance
j'ai beaucoup travaillé
oui vous avez beaucoup travaillé parce
que vous avez fait des têtes diplôme de
sciences po plus une thèse de doctorat
et en même temps à l'époque vous vous
commencé à militer d'une certaine façon
puisque vous faites des articles très
critiques sur la présence française en
algérie non c'est juste c'est gonflé
parce que nous étions accueillis dans ce
pays est ce que c'était pas j'en suis
fait engueuler par mon oncle qui m'a dit
tu n'as pas le droit d'être un hôte de
la phrase est de critiquer la politique
française
votre oncle wassef exactement je viens
ensuite nasser arrive
mais malgré la réforme agraire le fait
que beaucoup des terres de votre famille
soit confisquée par le nouveau pouvoir
vous participez au régime de nasser oui
dans la mesure je partageais entièrement
sa politique étrangère de non-alignement
non alignement libération en afrique
fédération arabe mouvement afro
asiatique vous était un des théoriciens
de l'utilisation du pétrole comme une
espèce d'armes atomiques du tiers monde
à l'époque et vous devenez rapidement
mini des affaires étrangères d'egypte
donc soul sadate au moment de la visite
de sadate à jérusalem c'est vous qui
êtes en poste alors on a dit souvent que
c'est vous qui aviez écrit le discours
de de sadate à jérusalem s'est passé
vraiment discours il ya eu un autre
discours voilà pourquoi il était trop
sais pas peut-être été trop intellectuel
troc académique il est quelque chose qui
puisse mobiliser les opinions publiques
alors ensuite vous militez d'une
certaine façon pour la reconnaissance
d'israël son intégration au sein du
monde arabe
vous pensez une sorte de hong kong
penser qu'israël pourrait être à
l'époque une sorte de hong kong
mais il aurait fallu qu israël sarabi
c'est à dire se tourner vers lorient
plutôt que vers l'occident
c'est juste mais ça ça sa barque depuis
40 ans oui je ne pense plus
qu'aujourd'hui elle a des nouveaux
problèmes
ouais alors à l'époque on vous preniez
cette solution vous accusez de
défaitisme de reddition j'ai beaucoup de
mal à l'époque ses idées ses on nous
avait accusés d'avoir tué un traité une
île est une paix séparée dont nous
avions l'opposition des européens
l'opposition du monde arabe du groupe
islamique de la russie la seule
puissance qui nous aider c'était des
états unis met alors en 1992 est nommé
secrétaire général des nations unies de
l'onu vous arrivez dans votre bureau
trente huitième étage de la maison de
verre de nouilles à des roses et fally
s'appelle la maison de verre et au début
vous découvrez que la bureaucratie
onusienne est encore plus lourde que la
bureaucratie égyptienne oui ouais mais
la bureaucratie égyptienne était
inspirée de la bureaucratie française
vous passé cinq ans à l'onu mme de bilan
est assez positif sur des points comme
le salvador le mozambique le cambodge
guatemala afrique du sud fin de
l'apartheid enfin une victoire
vous étiez aussi l'origine de la
création des tribunaux internationaux en
bosnie rwanda la conférence sur
l'environnement de rio janeiro
et puis aussi des missions préventive
des casques bleus c'est quelque chose
qui était fort macédoine c'est qu'on
envoie les casques bleus avant que quand
la guerre éclate
est ce que vous appelez le peace
building c'est à dire une fois que la
guerre a eu lieu de consolider la paix
l'idée très simple c'est comme quand
vous quitter l'hôpital la période de
convalescence est plus importante que la
période vous avez passé à l'hôpital le
plus souvent bien nations unies une fois
que l'opération est terminée veulent
quitter et ne s'intéressent plus à la
situation conflictuelle 1
or ce qui compte c'est la période de
convalescence parce que vous avoir une
rechute très et c'est arrivé souvent
donc il faut construire la paix il faut
institutionnaliser il faut que je
trouvais ce cap et adenauer et de gaulle
des institutions communes entre les deux
communautés
alors ce qu elles négatives dans votre
viande l'ex yougoslavie
l'angola le mali liberia
oui vous avez oublié l'essentiel je ne
suis pas arrivé être en bons termes avec
les etats-unis maïs est un échec ça ils
vous ont viré parce que d'habitude on
fait deux mandats sur d'habitude
cantonné général de l'onu on fait deux
mandats la suite vous je n'ai fait qu'un
seul à cause d'un veto américain se sont
opposés à votre réélection au bout du
premier mandat parce que vous étiez trop
indépendant par rapport à eux j'imagine
mans c'est très simple je dis peut-être
secrétaire général peut-être le
secrétaire d état
mais de temps en temps il faut être un
général on voulait un sacré tel il ne
voulait pas de générer ouais alors ils
ont pris kofi annan qui est sans doute
plus deux chiffres que vous c'est une
des règles ne faut jamais parler ni de
ses succès s'est répétée cette arrivée
des diplomates
non mais c'est vrai qu'ils nous ont bien
dormir des américains bob doll qui était
candidat
à la présidence américaine vous appelez
bout trausse galice qui puisse qu'on en
fait apprendre les langues ce soir bout
en anglais c'est comme ou en france ah
oui n'accepte d'akbou oualalou trop
d'américains à la jolie effective enfin
c'est la discrimination raciale
c'est que ça a dit écoutez ça nous vaut
des applaudissements j'ai besoin de
réussir aux élections et il continue et
parfaitement démago votre avis sur le
fonctionnement de l'onu aujourd'hui je
répandrai la même question j'ai le pendu
tout à l'heure il faut jamais parler de
son successeur un peu dingue de bois je
pose une vraie question un petit peu
peut-être après choquant mais bon les
français ont envie de savoir est ce
qu'il ya vraiment des ferrero chez
l'ambassadeur
et cheyrou
ouais c'est quoi des ferrero chocolat
énorme
non monsieur boutros ghali au kosovo par
exemple
l'onu n'a même pas été consultés l'otan
est intervenue j'ai déclaré que c'était
intervention est est illégale
voilà ah oui certainement voilà je vous
demande pas dire du mal de votre
successeur mais franchement l'onu a
beaucoup moins d'importance aujourd'hui
quelle époque où vous en étiez le
secrétaire général est ce que si j'avais
continué je pense qu'elle aurait eu
moins d'importance aussi avant que parce
que la superbe l'hyperpuissance
américaine n'accepte pas qu'on puisse la
contredire est ce que le 11 septembre
n'a pas été une occasion ratée pour le
nude elle aurait pu redevenir le fer de
lance de l'action multilatérale alors
finalement les états unis l'a été les
premiers jours le 12 septembre une
résolution du conseil de sécurité votée
à l'unanimité
donc on a créé un certain moment que les
états unis et j'en paie le let
ils empêchent les 700 millions de
dollars tout de suite oui donc on a créé
un certain moment que les états unis
allaient revenir au multilatéralisme
qu'il allait collaborer avec les nations
unies
ils se sont rendu compte par la suite
qu'ils pouvaient faire toutes les
opérations tout seuls et ils sont
revenus à leur unilatéralisme et là en
ce moment là les nations unies ont perdu
toute importance très fort comme le
reste de la communauté internationale se
livrait pas c'est que c'est définitif
pour le nez non je pense que s'il ya une
volonté politique de la part de certains
états si demain l'union européenne vont
avoir une politique étrangère
si demain la chine décide de jouer un
rôle nous allons revenir à un minimum de
démocratisation des relations
internationales
on y arrive dit que le nu c'est le seul
endroit où pourrait avoir lieu la
démocratisation de la mondialisation
c'est le titre de votre livre c'est quoi
la démocratisation d'un mondialisme
écoutez nous sommes en train
d'encourager la démocratie nationale
or l'état est en train de perdre de plus
en plus sa compétence puisque les
événements les plus importants que ce
soit le terrorisme que ce soit les
finances que cela les problèmes
d'environnement ne peuvent pas être
riche
lui à l'échelle nationale donc à ce
moment on dit ça sert à quoi de de
vouloir encourager la démocratie
nationale
si à l'échelle internationale à
l'échelle planétaire
vous avez un système qui n'est pas
démocratique c'est clair alors visite le
11 septembre a marqué le début du xxième
siècle comme l'attentât de sarajevo
avait marqué le début du xxème
alors désormais le nucléaire du pauvre
c'est plus que votre époque le pétrole
c'est le terrorisme le danger ce que ce
terrorise est devenue internationale
tels que la lutte contre le terrorisme
se fait toujours à l'échelle nationale
bref c'est d'où la faiblesse la
situation vient d'orient vous la voyez
évolué et comment je suis pessimiste
les casques bleus peuvent payer les
écouter le seul espoir c'est que les
états unis décident intervenir qu on
puisse avoir des forces d'interposition
entre les palestiniens des israéliens
qui a une véritable volonté politique de
faire quelque chose cette volonté
n'existe pas mais là je voudrais dire
que quand il ya eu un génocide au rwanda
il n'y avait pas la même volonté en y
avait une indifférence de la communauté
internationale
il ya une volonté d'intervenir mais
israélien refuse une force
d'interposition et à ce moment là les
serbes refusent et des forces
d'interposition leur imposer des forces
il faut imposer des forces
d'interposition près que c'est possible
c'est possible certainement pour les
amériques arrive à rien que colin powell
a passé une semaine là bas et qui est
reparti sans rien avoir fait ça je ne
sais pas si c'est vraiment c'est la
politique américaine y a des elle doit
avoir un lobby qui puissants ils n'ont
pas pris une décision il se peuvent
qu'ils ont d'autres priorités
n'oubliez pas qu'une puissance une super
puissance sont un s'occupe de 12
opérations en même temps ils ont ce
moment d'afghanistan il en ce moment 1
le problème entre et la corée du sud et
la corée du nord il
ils ont des problèmes au congo ils ont
des problèmes il ya une guerre
actuellement jour j il ya un autre
guerre entre l'art minière hébergeant
vous avez une douzaine de guerre quels
qu'ils suivent de très près il se peut
que il décide que ce qu'ils attachent
plus d'importance à l'irak que cas la
solution du problème mais il faut
espérer que devant la dégradation de la
situation il soit mais agir passé
aujourd'hui clairement que l'électorat
juif aux états unis interdit au
président bush d'intervenir
militairement ou à travers le nu au
moyen-orient je ne pense pas je pense au
contraire est-ce qu'on est arrivé à
convaincre à faire convaincre
l'administration américaine que
terrorisme de ben laden exa et et égale
le terrorisme des palestiniens donc si
vous luttez contre le terrorisme vous
devez lutter contre le terrorisme
palestinien
ils en sont persuadés on est arrivé à
les persuader de arafat égale ben laden
peau est maintenant dans une certaine
mesure louis pas pour tout le monde mais
dans une certaine mesure oui c'est pour
ça qu'ils font rien pour les
palestiniens
c'est pourquoi il hésite n'ont pas
encore pris une décision aussi la
situation s'aggrave peut-être vivante
agi si je suis à grasse qu'est-ce qu'il
peut y avoir de vie brave que djénine je
suis d'accord
il faut espérer qu'il n'y a pas un
second jénine mais alors là c'est le
rôle de l'europe
si l'opinion publique européenne faisait
pression sur les états unis la semaine
où il pourrait avoir une réaction
et s'il ya une pression qui vient de
l'europe une pression qui vient du japon
des indes la chine je pense qu'à ce
moment izagirre mais nous nous trouvons
face à une très grande lassitude
générale face aux différents conflits
qui sont en train d'en sanglante et le
monde il ya plus de conflits que du
temps de la liste ouest que du temps de
l'urss
oui oui certains n'ont plus eu
finalement voulait dire que la guerre
froide était meilleure balle était moins
chaudes oui oui puis non
non parce que ce moment vous aviez quand
même une menace d'utilisation de l'arme
atomique et vous aviez une suite de
guerre qui se passait par interposition
vous aviez la gare au mozambique
vous aviez la guerre en angola vous
aviez une guerre entre l'ethiopie et la
somalie
vous aviez la guerre au vietnam la via
la gare en corée toutes ces guerres
c'était des guerres qui avait lieu à
travers les deux super puissances qui
chacune à puis un des deux protagonistes
du conflit
vous êtes à modérer boutros boutros
ghali encore beaucoup de gens comme vous
dans les pays arabes
je pense que vous retrouvez ces modérés
aussi bien israël que dans les pays
arabes pour le moment face à ce que nous
vivons
ils sont minoritaires mais il suffit que
on arrive à trouver un début de solution
pour que de minorités il devient
majoritaire a le sentiment qu'on a ici
c'est que les américains aient d'israël
mais que les pays arabes riches comme
l'arabie saoudite par exemple n'aide pas
les palestiniens l'aide lettre qu'il
donne c'est une aide financière
ils n'ont pas les moyens de donner une
autre aide c'est une aide diplomatique
dans lequel il envoie des messagers
auprès des autorités américaines pour
leur dire hip hop elle quelque chose
mais n'ont pas les moyens donnés de
donner une aide je dirais militaire
l'armée israélienne est appuyé
et par toute une logistique de la super
puissance donc en réalité c'est la super
puissance qui joue un rôle important
ça s'appelle démocratiser la
mondialisation c'est aux éditions du
rocher
boutros boutros ghali entretien avec
yves berteloot